bonjour et bienvenue pour cette fois en
question stop sciences ou aujourd'hui
nous allons tenter de faire le point
ensemble sur la nouvelle découverte le
nouvel os mot l'aumône à lady alors au
monal ai dit c'est une nouvelle espèce
d'hominidé dont la découverte a été
annoncée le 10 septembre 2015
à grand renfort de presse de
retransmission simultanée internationale
sur la chaîne télé de national
geographic mais aussi de façon plus
intéressante par deux articles qui ont
été publiés dans la revue à comité de
lecture il ait une revue en ligne et en
libre accès donc vous pouvez y accéder
totalement gratuitement il juste à y
aller à télécharger l'article en pdf et
vous l'avez entre les mains je vous
mettrai les liens dans la description et
si jamais vous avez la flemme de lire
les articles et bien vous pouvez d'ores
et déjà chuté sur notre vidéo dans
laquelle nous avons filmé la
présentation de la découverte de mona
lady et traduit sous-titré de ce que
disaient les chercheurs donc l'iburger
notamment qui est le principal auteur de
cette découverte est comme ça vous serez
au courant de quoi on parle si jamais
vous avez manqué l'annoncé de la
découverte de mona les 10 alors au monal
édile a été découvert par une équipe
principalement sud-africaine de
chercheurs et l'annoncé de cette
découverte a été reçu avec énormément de
scepticisme de la part de la communauté
des paléoanthropologues partout ailleurs
dans le monde
que ce soit aux états unis en europe en
france par exemple est ce scepticisme il
est plus ou moins justifiées
d'une part par le fait que ces
découvertes sont très préliminaires
vraiment très très préliminaires ils
n'ont fait que réellement que gratter la
surface au sens propre comme au sens
figuré et d'autre part il faut savoir
que le milieu paléoanthropologie que la
recherche paléoanthropologie que c'est
un milieu extrêmement compétitif il ya
beaucoup de chercheurs qui publient
énormément et il ya beaucoup de
concurrence entre laboratoires et même
parfois à l'intérieur des laboratoires
ce qui fait qu'en fait les chercheurs
ont plus vite fait de casser les
découvertes des autres que de se
féliciter constat processus totalement
humains mais voilà
ce scepticisme il est partagé entre des
critiques qui sont justes et des
critiques qui le sont peut-être un peu
moins parfois donc ce que je vais
essayer dans cette vidéo et bien ceux de
faire la part des choses entre le bon le
mauvais avec le plus d'objectivité
possible
donc je vais essayer quand même de vous
présenter les choses de la façon la plus
neutre possible mais sachez que je suis
quand même plutôt au monal et dit
enthousiaste que au monal et dit
sceptique mais vous allez voir que j'ai
quand même des critiques
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
des trois points principaux qui ont fait
débat l'attribution taxonomique
l'absence de datation et la potentielle
existence d'un culte des morts chez homo
na li
donc en gros on va essayer de répondre
aux questions bien de quelle espèce
s'agit-il
s'agit-il d'ailleurs d'une nouvelle
espèce pourquoi n'ont ils pas dater le
gisement comment pourrait-on daté
gisement est enterré t-il réellement ces
morts alors commençons par le premier
point qui à mon sens est le moins
intéressant mais qui paradoxalement est
celui qui a fait couler le plus d'encre
l'attribution taxonomique alors petit
point sur ce qu'est la taxonomie la
taxonomie ce n'est ni plus ni moins que
la classification alors pourquoi on
préfère employer le mot taxonomie que le
mot classification tout simplement parce
que taxonomie ça vient de taxons du mot
taxe honte et ax au n est qu est ce qu
un taxon et bien de la même manière que
les atomes les bosons les quartz sont
des particules l'espèce le genre la
famille l'embranchement le fil homme
tout ça ce sont des taxes ont donc ce
sont des unités taxonomique si vous
voulez ce sont des unités de
classification donc à partir de
maintenant je vais vous parler non plus
de classification mais taxonomie est par
moments au lieu d'employer le mot
espèces ou le mot genre où le mot
famille je vais employer le mot taxons
parce que c'est un mot qui est beaucoup
plus neutre
il ya tout un grand débat sur quelle est
la valeur de l'espèce en tant qu'unité
taxonomique à savoir qu'aujourd'hui si
on est capable de séparer un chimpanzé
d'un humain et de dire qu'il s'agit de
deux espèces différentes c'est
uniquement parce que tous les
intermédiaires entre le chimpanzé et
l'humain depuis leur ancêtre commun ont
disparu mais si tous ces intermédiaires
existait et bien vous aurez le chimpanzé
noir vous aurez l'être humain en blanc
et vous auriez tous les niveaux de gris
possibles entre les deux de telle façon
qu à aucun moment vous ne pourriez
tracer une limite entre le chimpanzé
l'homme assez ce qui arriverait si
toutes les espèces qu'il y avait entre
le chimpanzé l'homme existait toujours
le fait est qu'elles n'existent plus
donc dans le monde actuel on est capable
de dire
j'ai repensé et hommes sont séparés une
fois qu'on regarde dans le registre
fossile
ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué voilà
pourquoi je vais vous parler de taxons
et non plus d'espèces parce que c'est
beaucoup plus simple au moins c'est un
terme beaucoup plus neutre on va dire on
perd un petit peu d'informations au
niveau de l'unité qu'on utilise mais au
moins c'est un terme beaucoup plus
neutre
alors qui est homo naledi présentation
au monal et 10 c est un assemblage de 15
squelette d'hominidé découvert dans une
chambre elle-même située rue le fond
d'une grotte et cette quinzaine de
squelette d'hominidé sera certainement
accompagné dans un futur proche de
beaucoup plus d'autre matériel parce que
les fouilles sont très compliquées et
que pour l'instant ils se sont contentés
d'un ramassage de surface c'est à dire
que en gros il ya une surface de 1 mètre
carré qu'ils ont réellement fouillés en
creusant plus le ramassage de tout ce
qu'ils disent est sur le fond de la
grotte
donc ça c'est déjà quinze spécimens mais
il y en a certainement beaucoup plus a
déterré en dessous et pour ça il va
falloir creuser mais la grotte étant
très difficile d'accès ce c'est pas pour
tout de suite
il ya un trou qui fait 18 cm dans la
vidéo que j'ai traduite
j'avais cru comprendre qu'il disait 80
cm de large pour le trou puisque en
anglais 80 et 18 ça se ressemble
beaucoup mais j'ai revérifié c'est bien
18 cm de large
donc le trou il fait 18 cm de large donc
tout est rentré c'est pas facile c'est
déjà vachement bien qu'ils aient trouvé
des gens capables d'y rentrer mais voilà
ça ça facilite pas les foules du coup il
ya encore beaucoup de matériel qui est
au fond du trou
alors qu'est ce qu'il a de particulier
et bien aux monnaies lady un pied dont
le pouce n'est pas opposable et ça c'est
typique du genre homo un pied à pouce
non opposable il n'y a pas plu aux mots
que ça ensuite il a une main qui
apparemment aurait un pouce très long
qui vont regarder un chimpanzé par
exemple les doigts de l'index jusqu à
l'auriculaire sont très longues mais le
pouce est relativement court c'est une
adaptation à la suspension dans les
arbres au monde à lady lui il a des
doigts donc de l'index jusqu à
l'auriculaire qui sont très longs mais
il a aussi un pouce qui est très très
long et les phalanges des doigts son arc
et comme chez le chimpanzé donc il
aurait une sorte de combinaison de
caractère humain un pouce très long et
primitif donc des phalanges arqués et
des doigts de l'index jusqu à
l'auriculaire relativement long bon
après faut savoir que ces caractères de
la main notamment la longue
or du pouce c'est quelque chose qui est
très discuté parce qu'il semblerait que
l'ancêtre commun des nominés es tu déjà
un pouce relativement long et enfin un
volume crânien relativement faible par
rapport à l'homme actuelle un tiers de
la taille du volume cérébral humain
actuel de l'ordre de 5 centimètres cubes
donc 400 500 centimètres cubes
c'est ce qu'on s'attend à trouver chez
un australopithèque c'est aussi quelque
chose qu'on trouve chez homo habilis et
c'est aussi quelque chose qu'on retrouve
chez l'homme de florès l'homme de florès
qui n'a que dix-huit mille ans et qui a
lui aussi un cerveau de l'ordre de 400
500 centimètres cubes
voilà ce petit volume crânien n'exclut
pas qu'on le classe dans le genre homo
et la morphologie du pied apparemment
ferait de cette espèce un représentant
du genre homo de même que la longueur
des jambes
il semblerait que le fémur soit très
long et relativement fins comme chez les
homos pu dériver donc le lait caractère
apparemment pointe vers le genre homo
puisque les caractères qui font
ressembler au monal et 10 à un
australopithèque le volume crânien
notamment sont primitifs et on ne classe
pas à partir de caractère primitif il a
des innovations morphologie partagé avec
le genre mot donc il a un ancêtre commun
avec le genre au monde les caractère
primitif eux sont hérités d'un ancêtre
plus lointain on ne classe pas accès car
là puisqu'ils ne sont pas représentatifs
de l'existence d'un ancêtre commun donc
attributions taxonomique de mona lady
concernant l'attribution spécifique de
mona lee dit il va falloir déjà faire un
gros rappel sur ce qu'implique une
classification parce que depuis darwin
depuis la théorie de l'évolution
classification et phylogénie sont
totalement indissociables la
classification doit refléter la
phylogénie donc la phylogénie pour ceux
qui connaîtraient pas c'est juste la
représentation des liens de parenté
entre les espèces on ne fait pas de
généalogie normalement quand on est aux
log botanistes biologistes parce que les
espèces actuelles ne descendent pas les
unes des autres elles descendent d'un
ancêtre commun
donc on fait des phylogénie sur lesquels
on représente les degrés de parenté
entre les individus et pas leur lien de
parenté direct la classification elle
doit refléter ces degré de parenté
c'est à dire qu'on devrait pas mettre
dans une même boîte dans un même temps
que sont deux espèces qui ne sont pas
proches parentes l'être humain le
chimpanzé on les met dans la même boîte
celle des hominidés parce qu'ils sont
proches parents et après l'être humain
et les fossiles comme australopithèques
ou dubaï son plus proche parent les uns
des autres
qu'ils ne le sont avec le chimpanzé donc
on va les mettre dans une boîte plus
petit qui reflète ce lien de parenté
boîte plus petit qu'on a appelé les
homininés donc ça c'est une
classification qui reflète la phylogénie
donc idéalement toute classification
toute attribution taxonomique et y
compris celle de homo naledi devrait
refléter une phylogénie problème en
paléoanthropologie la plupart des
chercheurs ne réfléchissent pas encore
de cette façon
idéalement on devrait faire ça depuis
darwin mais c'est pas le cas on ne fait
pas ça depuis darwin pourquoi parce que
il nous manquait des techniques d'une
part et d'autre part il ya une raison
historique c'est que la classification
des espèces a existé bien avant darwin
donc au moment où la théorie de
l'évolution sort on sait déjà faire des
classifications ou du moins on croit
savoir et de ce fait et bien les
classifications n'ont pas tout de suite
refléter la phylogénie puisqu'on a
conservé les vieilles classification et
puis dans les années 1970 on a inventé
une nouvelle technique qui s'appelle la
khl a dit stick qui a été une des
premières techniques vraiment efficace
pour reconstruire des arbres évolutif et
à partir de là on a pu construire des
arbres évolutive donc des phylogénie et
on a pu faire des classifications qui
reflétait ces arbres évolutif mais tout
le monde s'y est pas mis tout de suite
avec la mystique et tout le monde s'est
pas mis tout de suite à la pensée
phylogénétique et pour des raisons
historiques et bien chez les
paléoanthropologues il reste encore une
grande part de chercheurs qui ne
réfléchissent pas encore de cette façon
dont qui ne réfléchissent pas encore en
termes de fil au génie mais qui pense
encore l'évolution des hominidés et des
homininés en termes de lignes et c'est
une généalogie on va relier les espèces
les unes aux autres dans l'ordre
chronologique c'est généralement ce que
vous voyez sur internet vous tapez le
phylogénie des zones humides et où vous
tapez évolution de l'homme ou quoi que
ce soit ce que vous allez voir et bien
cdc des crânes de mimine et qui vont
être disposées dans le temps voilà dans
l'ordre chronologique dans l'ordre qu'on
appelle stratigraphique en l'occurrence
et puis on va les reliés les uns aux
autres de telle façon que le plus ancien
sera l'ancêtre du plus récent et ainsi
de suite jusqu'à l'homme moderne
c'est cette pensée en termes de lignes
et qui a conduit à ce fameux même de la
marche vers le progrès là où on voit un
sage se redresser et devenir un être
humain et ça c'est pas une
représentation qui est fondamentalement
fausse mais c'est une représentation qui
pose de
ross hypothèses des normes d'hypothèses
en l'occurrence vous savez tous qu'à
chaque fois qu'on découvre une nouvelle
espèce d'hominidé on déclare que c'est
l'ancêtre de l'homme et la probabilité
que le crâne que vous tenez dans la main
à un moment donné soit celui de
l'ancêtre de l'homme elle est quasiment
nulle pour que ce crâne fossile est
appartenu à un individu qui soit
l'ancêtre de l'homme il faut qu'ils
fassent directement partie de la
généalogie qui a mené à l'ancêtre commun
d'homo sapiens les sas sas est
infiniment improbable dis pas que c'est
impossible mais c'est infiniment
improbable et en traçant des lignes en
pointillés qui mène d'un crâne à un
autre de cette façon vous multipliez les
infinis improbabilité par autant qu'il y
à des espèces fossiles dans votre
généalogie ça c'est problématique donc
l'avantagent de la phylogénie par
rapport à la généalogie c'est qu'on va
économiser ces hypothèses chaque espèce
va finir en bout de branche d'un arbre
qui ne nous donnera que les degrés
relatif de parenté des espèces les unes
par rapport aux autres
donc cette démarche de construction de
phylogénie elle oblige aussi à
formaliser ces observations d'une façon
qui soit quantifiable et convertibles en
0 et en un
on va convertir nos observations sur des
caractéristiques d'un crâne donc voilà
la présence ou non d'un bourrelet par
dessus leurs beats la taille des arcades
jus galles on va dire si elles sont
grandes si elles sont petites
la forme du palais est ce qu'il est
plutôt de forme rectangulaire ou est-ce
qu'il est plutôt de forme arrondie la
taille des canines est-ce qu'elles sont
petites est-ce qu'elles sont rois toutes
ces observations là on va les
transformer en ligne 2 0 et 2 1
on va les rentrées dans un ordinateur et
c'est l'ordinateur qui va faire le
calcul
ce qui fait que voilà des trucs du type
dire que tel processus est légèrement
plus prononcée à l'arrière du crâne que
tel truc et légèrement plus long que tel
autre à lhassa non ça peut pas passer
pour une fille le génie n'arriverait pas
à le convertir en donner en données qui
peuvent être traités par un ordinateur
donc ça oblige aussi à faire des
observations qu'ils soient carrées et
reproductibles par chacun et ensuite
c'est l'ordinateur qui va traiter on a
différents modes de traitement pour
faire défiler au génie dont il ya la
méthode cladistique original on va dire
qui consiste à faire une analyse ans
maximum de parcimonie
en gros c'est le rasoir d'occam et vous
avez deux 2 autres techniques technique
par maximum de vraisemblance et la
technique bayésienne qui sont donc des
techniques beaucoup plus statistiques
beaucoup plus compliqué
donc ya pas que la classe distique
classique qui permet de reconstruire des
arbres évolutif si on utilise des
techniques de phylogénie c'est parce
qu'elles permettent même si elles sont
plus compliquées à la base elles
permettent à la fin d'obtenir une
classification qui est plus facile à
lire
concernant au monal et dit beaucoup de
paléontologues ont avancé l'argument que
son cerveau était trop petit et que du
coup il devait s'agir d'un
australopithèque us et pas d'un
représentant du genre homo et ça comme
affirmation ça pose énormément de
problèmes
du point de vue phylogénétique parce que
australopithecus est défini par des
caractère primitif et notamment par la
petite taille de son cerveau alors déjà
quelle est la définition
d'australopithecus il faut savoir que le
pivot la pierre angulaire
d'australopithecus le représentant de
référence du genre australopithèques us
ce n'est pas lui si mais l'enfant de
tang l'enfant de tang c'est
australopithecus africanus alors que
l'uci s'est australopithecus afarensis
c'est une autre espèce donc voilà le
point de repère de votre genre
australopithecus il faut que ça reste
l'enfant de temps ou si une espèce
ressemble à l'enfant de tang
on va dire que c'est un australopithèque
si elle ne lui ressemble pas on va dire
que c'est autre chose
alors quand on dit par exemple qu'une
nouvelle espèce comme lucie appartient
au genre australopithèques on
sous-entend par ce terme de
classification par cette appartenance au
genre australopithecus qu'elle est plus
proche de l'enfant de tang que de
n'importe quel autre espèce de mini
n'est donc ça veut dire que si on admet
l'existence d'australopithèques us en
tant qu'unité taxonomique il faut qu'il
y ait un ancêtre commun à tous les
australopithèques et que tous les
descendants de cet ancêtre commun
doivent porter le même nom et soit nommé
australopithecus ça semble logique vous
avez le même nom de famille que vos
ancêtres
pourquoi pas ce que vous faites partie
de la même famille parce que vous êtes
tous issus d'un ancêtre commun
le problème avec australopithèques c'est
que ça se passe pas du tout comme ça les
espèce d'australopithèque ne sont pas
toutes apparentées à l'enfant de tang
est pour ainsi dire y'en a quasiment
aucune qui est plus apparente et à
l'enfant de tang qu'à n'importe quel
autre australopithèques donc là vous
avez une phylogénie des hominidés une
bref il au génie des hommes une idée
était publié en juillet 2015
un petit peu avant que homo naledi ne
soit annoncée donc au monal et dit ne
fait pas partie de cette phylogénie mais
cette phylogénie et bien nous
juste parfaitement le problème qu'il y
as avec le fait de classifier une espèce
dans le jean australopithèques dans une
file au génie ça se lit depuis la base
donc la racine qui est à gauche jusqu'à
ses feuilles
c'est à dire les espèces le nom des
espèces à droite de l'image
donc ça se lit dans le sens dans lequel
un arbre touche en réalité et on va
suivre donc la croissance de 7 arbres et
les branches qui en émanent et ça ça va
vous montrer quel est le problème avec
australopithecus donc on démarre à la
racine d'ancêtre commun des homininés
qui donne naissance à ça et l'entreprise
jaden 6 donc toumaï puis la roue
continue de grandir il donne naissance à
une deuxième branche qui est
ardipithecus ramidus puis on arrive à
l'ancêtre commun des australopithèques
donc là on pourrait mettre un point
rouge puisque toutes les branches en
rouge représentent des branches qui mène
un une espèce du genre australopithèques
australopithèques us donc la première
branche d'australopithecus semaine un
australopithecus afarensis puis l'arbre
continue de croître
une branche part à droite et donne
naissance à australopithecus afarensis
et australopithecus dugarry l'arbre
croit encore et on arrive à la branche
qui mène à australopithecus africanus le
fameux enfants de tongs donc le point de
repère du genre australopithèques
l'arbre croit encore on passe par
l'ancêtre commun du genre homo est une
branche qui mène à homo habilis mêle
aussi à australopithecus sediba est donc
là quand vous constatez que
australopithecus sediba est à
l'intérieur du genre homo je pense que
vous avez compris le problème
pourquoi parce que on a des
australopithèques absolument partout et
certains australopithèques comme
australopithecus sediba qui sont plus
proches du genre homo que de
australopithecus africanus le point de
repère je le rappel du genre
australopithèques c'est à dire que pour
que tous ces australopithèques fasse
partie du genre australopithèques us
réellement pour que tous soient
descendant d'un unique ancêtre commun
il faudrait que toutes les branches
rouge convergent dans la racine de la
branche australopithecus africanus c'est
le seul moyen pour que le genre
australopithèques us soit 1 groupes
taxonomiques reflétant une réalité
phylogénétique le seul cas où tous les
australopithèques us soit les
descendants d'un unique ancêtre commun
mais là le problème c'est que
être commun des australopithèques eh
bien ce n'est pas seulement l'ancêtre
commun aux australopithèques c'est aussi
l'ancêtre commun à sept branches bleus
qui mène vers gagnent entre opus c'est
aussi si on suit cette ligne rouge
l'ancêtre commun à part entre opus ici
en verre et si on continue de suivre la
ligne rouge c'est aussi l'ancêtre commun
au genre homo alors vous allez me dire
ben oui mais il y en a qui ont dit que
homo habilis c'était pas un homo c'était
un australopithèque aussi bas faisons le
considérons homo habilis comme issue
d'une ramification d'une branche rouge
et bah ça change rien même si on dit que
ces australopithèques us habilis et bien
il ya toujours une branche rouge qui
d'un côté va donner naissance à des
australopithèques mais qui de l'autre
côté va donner naissance au genre homo
voilà la classification des homininés
telle qu'elle est conçu actuellement ne
reflète pas une réalité phylogénétique
en tout cas pas dans le cas du genre
australopithèques kenyan trope ya qu'une
espèce donc ça pose pas de problème pas
rentrer opus ça pose pas de problème
puisque vous voyez que un ancêtre commun
correspond la naissance de trois espèces
qui reste des descendants de l'unique
ancêtres apparente plus mais homo ça
marche pas donc en gros si vous
considérez que australopithecus sediba
est un représentant du genre homo et
bien dans ce cas l'ancêtre commun du
genre homo et bien l'ancêtre de tous les
homos par contre si vous dites que
australopithecus sediba ne fait pas
partie du genre homo
alors là l'ancêtre commun du genre homo
il n'existe pas puisqu'il y en a une
partie qui est australopithèque et si
vous excluez homo habilis alors là
éventuellement vous avez de nouveau à
d'ancêtres communs du genre au monde ce
qui n'enlève toujours pas le problème à
la définition même des australopithèques
donc l'ancêtre commun des
australopithèques c'est aussi l'ancêtre
de kenyans trope c'est aussi l'ancêtre
de parent trap c'est aussi l'ancêtre du
genre homo quelles que soient les
alternatives que vous envisagez ce qui
fait que en termes de classification et
bien on est tous compris dans la boîte
des australopithèques si vous gardez la
taxonomie telle qu'elle est actuellement
nous devrions tous être considérés comme
des australopithèques de la même façon
que les oiseaux doivent être considérées
comme des dinosaures
pourquoi est ce que ces problématiques
de dire que homo naledi appartient au
genre australopithèques c'est parce que
deux bad australopithèque et très mal
défini tous les australopithèques ne
sont pas proches parents de l'enfant de
tongs dans la vision proche parent de
homo il y en a qui sont proches parents
par entretien avec son proche parent de
kenyans 30 donc les australopithèques et
comme les pois
on sait comme les reptiles ça n'existe
pas c'est un groupe qui n'existe pas
c'est un groupe qui est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un groupe poubelle
voilà quand quand vous êtes à nominer
avec un petit cerveau en gros vous êtes
un australopithèque non parce que si
tout le reste de votre corps si c'est
comme australopithecus sediba par
exemple et que tout le reste de votre
corps indique que vous avez des beaucoup
de points communs avec homo pas
forcément vous êtes plus proche du genre
homo et après quand vous mettez à
rajouter des représentants du genre homo
avec un petit cerveau comme homo habilis
homo floresiensis et bien là on commence
à avoir des problèmes comme le problème
qu'on a juste en face de nous c'est à
dire homo habilis et australopithecus
sediba qui sont proches parents en fait
australopithèques us et ben c'est pas
réellement un genre c'est un grade un
grade pourquoi parce que depuis la
racine d'australopithecus et d'ancêtres
communs de tous les australopithèques et
de tous les hommes une idée qu'il y a
dans cette partie là de l'arbre eh bien
vous avez une gradation de caractère
depuis dé caractère primitif qui vont
donner un amen 6 jusqu'à des caractères
qui vont évoluer petit à petit de
naissance afarensis donnant naissance à
africanus donnant naissance à célibat
vous avez une gradation de caractère
depuis des caractères primitifs jusqu'à
les caractères dérivés et c'est pour ça
que australopithèques us et un grade est
pas un réel taxons et plus vous
trouverez une nouvelle espèce qui comble
les vides entre ce que vous appelez
australopithecus est ce que vous appelez
au mot et plus cette limite sera
difficile à définir et les avantages de
la réflexion en termes d'arbres c'est
qu'elle permet de tracer une limite au
moins elle permet de dire voilà à partir
de quand commence au mot quand on
réfléchit en termes d'arbres donc déjà
on se rend compte qu australopithèques
us c'est pas un très joli groupe mais en
plus on peut définir la limite du genre
homo si on inclut sediba dans le genre
homo alors la limite entre
australopithecus sediba se trouve à cet
endroit là de l'arbre est donc scellé
caractère qui apparaissent à cet endroit
de l'arbre qui vont définir le genre
homo par contre si on considère que homo
habilis n'est pas un homo mais un
australopithèque alors c'est les
caractères qui apparaîtront à ce niveau
de l'arbre qui vont définir le genre
homo et donc ça ça répond à la question
d'ailleurs qu'un grand
paléoanthropologue a posé il ya pas
longtemps dans une dans une grande revue
scientifique et où justement il se
plaignait qu'il n'y avait pas de réelle
définition du genre moba c'est pour ça
qu'il ya pas de définition de réelle
définition au genre mauss c'est parce
que trop peu de paléo anthropologues
réfléchissent en termes de fil au génie
plutôt qu'en termes de lignes
parce que si vous réfléchissez en termes
de fil au génie la limite du genre homo
est très facile à définir
on peut très facilement se mettre
d'accord grâce à un arbre donc est-ce
que mona lady est un australopithèque
oui parce que nous sommes tous des
australopithèques mais ça change rien je
ris blick australopithèques a besoin
d'une énorme révision taxonomique donc
maintenant il ya d'autres auteurs qui
ont dit que homo naledi pouvait être un
homo erectus primitif les espèces
primitives déjà ça n'existe pas trop
mais admettons qu'on ait compris l'idée
en gros il s'agirait d'un homo erectus
basale le problème c'est qu'encore une
fois homo erectus c'est comme
australopithèques us c'est un peu un
fourre tout où on met toutes les espèces
qu'on considère suffisamment évolué
entre guillemets pour faire partie du
genre homo mais pas assez pour être des
homos dérivés dont comment ils récusent
le problème voilà c'est que c'est un peu
à fourre tout c'est à dire qu'on y met
des espèces qui ont des caractères très
primitif notamment des espèces les
toutes premières les plus anciennes ont
un cerveau de l'ordre de 600 centimètres
cubes ce qui est à peine 200 centimètres
cubes au dessus de ce qu'on trouve chez
la moyenne des australopithèques jusqu'à
des espèces qui ont un cerveau de 1200
centimètres cubes voire plus c'est à
dire 200 centimètres cubes de moins
qu'au mot sapiens homo erectus il est un
peu comme australopithèques c'est un
grade
il a une gradation de caractère depuis
des caractères très primitive jusqu'à
des caractères très dérivés vous voyez
tout cette gradation de caractère là
elle fait qu'il ya une énorme
variabilité chez homo erectus une
gigantesque variabilité et ça fait qu'on
considère que homo erectus il a donné
naissance à tout un tas d'autres espèces
notamment vanté ses sorts et d'albert
guen si ces mêmes sapiens donc en fait
l'ancêtre commun de mots erectus dans
beaucoup de scénarios évolutifs c'est
aussi l'ancêtre de sapiens de néandertal
et de tout un tas d'autres homos erectus
c'est un fourre tout où on y admet
l'existence deux sous-espèces avec des
caractères très primitif et d'autres
avec des caractères très dérivés qui ont
pu donner naissance tout un tas
d'aspects d'autres espèces donc
maintenant pourquoi mettre au monal et
10 dans erectus ça poserait problème bas
déjà parce que homo erectus n'a pas lui
même des véritable existence en soi sauf
si on admet qu'on est nous mêmes des
homo erectus et homo erectus n'a pas de
vraie existence en soi et en plus au
moins d'aller dit il a un cerveau qui
est plus petit de l'ordre de 400 à 500
centimètres cubes
donc en gros on ferait encore que
élargir le panel de variabilité d'homo
erectus et ça c
c'est clairement pas la chose à faire
l'espèce qu'on appelle homo erectus
dispose déjà de bien assez de
variabilité comme ça et il est très
probable qu'à l'avenir des révisions
taxonomique pousse à le pousser en plus
petits morceaux dont ça s'est pas encore
sûr parce que depuis la découverte de ce
qu'on pense être une population d'homo
erectus athmane ici en géorgie
population qui montre une énorme
variabilité de caractère on se demande
si peut-être une partie de cette
variabilité ne serait pas naturelle là
où on aurait une variabilité
artificielle due au fait qu'on met plein
d'espèces différentes à l'intérieur
d'homo erectus là il y aurait peut-être
une part de cette variabilité qui serait
naturel au moins chez les plus anciens
représentants d'homo erectus et homo
naledi lui il a très très peu de
variabilité pour le coup les chercheurs
qui ont publié au monal et 10 sont
formels la variabilité chez les quinze
représentants de mona lady qui l'ont
découvert elle est très faible
a priori on serait sur une espèce qui
serait plutôt bien défini on aurait même
une espèce qui pour le coup serait mieux
défini comme au erectus donc là ce
serait dommage de l'inclure dans homo
erectus parce que ça lance ça enlèverait
une espèce qui a une certaine validité
pour la mettre dans une autre espèce qui
elle n'a aucune validité naledi est
beaucoup mieux défini kerekes tussna
lady est beaucoup mieux défini que
n'importe quel australopithèques donc
vaut mieux garder naledi tel qu'il est
plutôt que d'aller l'inclure dans lan ou
l'autre de ces groupes poubelle il faut
souligner le fait que dans cet article
il n'y a pas d' analyse phylogénétique
et ça c'est vraiment un gros problème
parce que on ne crée pas de nouvelles
espèces sans produire d' analyse
phylogénétique qui au moins montre que
cette espèce est valide qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un représentant d'une autre espèce
qu'on connaîtrait déjà donc ça à mon
avis c'est l'un des gros points faibles
de l'étude d'aumône à lady tout cas de
la présentation préliminaire de cette
espèce au moins aller dit c'est qu'ils
ont trop rapidement nous nommer cette
nouvelle espèce par rapport au fait
qu'il n'avait pas fait d'analysé
phylogénétique ça peut-être que ça
aurait mérité un peu prudent si long
qu'il ya deux écoles à partir de là
c'est soit publiée la description sans
donner de nom à l'espèce c'est un peu ce
qu'a fait ron clark qui est aussi un
chercheur sud-africain à propos de
little foot
il a dit que c'était un australopithèque
ce serait pas australopithecus africanus
mais il n'a pas encore donné de nom à
cette espèce alors peut-être que c'est
une nouvelle espèce
il y aurait une possibilité que ce soit
aussi
espèce qui a été nommé il ya très
longtemps dans les années 20 qui
s'appelle australopithecus prometheus
mais pour l'instant il n'y a pas de noms
qui ont été données et pareil pour le
mime idée de la cab auxerre donc un
hominidé beaucoup plus récent puisqu'il
aurait que douze mille ans cet hominidé
de la cave au serbe il n'est connu que
par le nom hominidés de la cave auxerre
ou peuple de la cave auxerre ils ont des
caractéristiques morphologiques très
différente des autres hominidés
mais pour l'instant leur a pas encore
donné le nom ont peut-être que cette
prudence aurait été nécessaire
ou alors quelque chose de très simple
aurait été possible c'était de faire une
analyse phylogénétique est là pour le
coup l'équipe de l'iburger donc la même
équipe qui a découvert
l'australopithecus sediba l'avait fait
pour australopithecus sediba quand ils
ont publié australopithecus sediba ils
ont fait une analyse phylogénétique qui
montrait que australopithecus sediba se
situer sur une branche de l'arbre qui
était indépendante et cette analyse
phylogénétique permettait de dire que
australopithecus sediba était plus
proche de l'homme
donc là il aurait pu produire une
analyse phylogénétique afin de soutenir
le fait que leur nouvel hominidé était
bien une nouvelle espèce parce que j'ai
vraiment pas compris c'est pourquoi ils
ne l'ont pas fait
il y a dans l'article un énorme tableaux
de données de plus de 80 caractère où
ils ont comparé tous les caractères du
crâne d'aumône à lady avec les autres
hominidés
vous avez un tableau avec des entrées
qui sont les espèces d'hominidés connu
d'autres entrées qui sont les caractères
et ils nous disent si ce caractère est
présent absent si le cerveau et petit
gros si le processus masto ide et de
grandes étendues ou de petites étendues
si le taurus supra orbitaire et épais ou
fin enfin bref il ya piètre tous ces
caractères là ils y sont tous tout ce
qu'ils avaient à faire c'était prendre
ces caractères les convertir en ligne et
2 0 et 2 1
les entrées dans un ordinateur dans un
logiciel phylogénétique et paf ça
ressentait une analyse phylogénétique je
les fais ça m'a pris une matinée et le
résultat qui en est sorti et qu'on
retrouve exactement le même arbre que
celui de dembo étals avec
australopithecus sediba qui s'enracine à
l'intérieur du genre homo et avec homo
naledi situerait à peu près au même
niveau qu'au moabi l'isq
australopithecus sediba ekomo erectus
donc à la base de l'arbre c'est très
variable d'un arbre à l'autre il ya neuf
arbres différents
on voit là il suffisait de faire ça pour
dire on a une nouvelle espèce
elle est indépendante des autres et elle
se branche à la base
delarbre évolutif du genre homo donc il
s'agit bien d'un représentant du genre
homo et ça ne demandait rien de nouveau
puisque cela les données que j'ai
utilisées c'est les leurs donc c'est
bizarre qu'il n'ait pas fait bon moi je
pense la raison pour laquelle ils n'ont
pas fait c'est que déjà dans leurs
tableaux il n'y a que des caractères
crânien il n'y a pas de caractère
dentaire il n'y a pas de caractère du
squelette que de 2 ils ont déjà une
quinzaine de squelette
mais ils savent qui en a beaucoup plus
dans la caverne qui reste donc je pense
qu'ils attendent des données
supplémentaires
et de trois je pense que s'ils l'ont
fait ils se sont rendus compte que
sediba tomber au milieu du genre homo et
que ça ça n'a pas dû leur plaire il
n'avait certainement pas envie de faire
la révision taxonomique de
l'australopithecus sediba en même temps
que l'annoncé de la découverte d'eau
mona lee
parce que si on suit cette analyse le
résultat de cette analyse il faut mettre
australopithecus sediba à l'intérieur du
genre go et en faire un homo célibat
donc voilà deux nouveaux membres du
genre homo dans un seul article
ça devait être un peu trop ils ont
peut-être jugé que c'était trop et que
du coup il valait mieux attendre
d'inclure les caractères dentaire
d'inclure les caractères du squelette
post crânien et de voir ce que ça
donnait avec une analyse vraiment
complète
je pense qu'il ya une analyse
phylogénétique qui est en préparation
ils ont déjà annoncé qu'ils avaient plus
qu'ils allaient être publiées évidemment
donc pour conclure sur l'attribution
taxonomique parce que ça peut vraiment
très longtemps là que j'en parle
vraiment très longtemps c'est le comme
je le disais c'est certainement le sujet
le moins intéressant parce que la
taxonomie c'est un outil créé par
l'homme et pour l'homme
donc c'est purement arbitraire c'est
complètement enfin c'est fascinant de
voir comment les êtres humains la traite
la taxonomie ce l'est beaucoup moins de
discuter directement de la taxonomie
mais voilà au moins à l'e10 est il un
représentant du genre homo ça en a tout
l'air
voilà ça en a tout l'air mais il faut
une révision du genre australopithecus
avant d'en être sûr au monal est dit est
il un homo erectus
si on décide de placer au moins aller
dit dans homo erectus ça ne fera que
accroître la variabilité d'homo erectus
ce qui ne fera que créer plus de
confusion souvent on a tendance à penser
que créer une nouvelle espèce a créé de
la confusion
le fait est que homo naledi et en
beaucoup mieux défini comme au erectus
c'est bien homo erectus qui crée de la
confusion mais pas aux monnaies les dix
au moins aller dit pourrait-il être homo
habilis c'est une possibilité le
problème de moi
lis c'est qu'il ya encore trop peu de
matériel connu homo habilis à un peu
souffre un peu du même problème comment
erectus c'est à dire qu'on lui a
attribué peut-être un peu trop de
matériel venant d'un peu trop d'endroits
différents
et du coup c'est pareil faut y aller
doucement en disant qu' au moins la
libye pourraient être au moins à billy
dans l'analyse que j'ai faite à partir
des données de l'article de bergues
heures il y a plusieurs arbres dans
lesquelles au monal eddy tombe à côté de
homo habilis et qui donc soutiendrait
l'idée que la lady et abily ce soit tous
les deux la même espèce c'est une
probabilité mais encore une fois il n'ya
que les caractères des trams il n'y ait
pas les caractères des dents il n'ya pas
les caractères du post crânien il n'ya
que une petite partie du matériel
puisque je le répète il ya encore
beaucoup de squelettes qui sont à
l'intérieur de la cave
donc voilà pour l'instant il vaut mieux
conserver naledi tel qu'il est en
sachant qu'il est très proche qu'il est
certainement très proche des milices et
en sachant que erectus et
australopithecus c'est juste des
alternatives qui créerait plus de
problèmes qu'elle n'en résoudrait
attaquons maintenant le problème de la
datation et notamment le problème de
l'absence de datation parce que
contrairement à ce que certains médias
ont annoncé
non on ne connaît pas la date exacte à
laquelle a vécu au monal est dit étant
donné la présence chez homo naledi de
certains caractère primitif notamment la
taille du cerveau
on suppose comme on allait dit doit être
une espèce d'hominidé relativement
ancienne de l'ordre de deux millions
d'années environ
évidemment je peux pas vous donner une
marge d'erreur parce que la marge
d'erreur est considérable il faut savoir
que dans le berceau de l'humanité
c'est-à-dire dans la région où se trouve
la grotte ou aumône à lady a été
découverte on a d'autres grottes qui ont
livré de nombreux restes d'hominidés et
que ces grottes comporte des sédiments
qui date en gros 2 4 millions d'années
jusqu'à cent mille ans mais c'est une
fourchette 1 4 million d'années cent
mille ans est un râteau donc voilà
aumône à l'e10 pourrait se situer en
théorie partout sur ce continuum de 4
millions d'années à cent mille ans
maintenant sachant sa morphologie
sachant l'analyse phylogénétique que
j'ai fait à partir de leurs données à
eux au moins aller dit il semblerait
qu'il se branche vraiment à la base du
genre homo
du côté de homo habilis du côté des
australopithecus sediba du côté de homo
erectus toutes ces espèces l' homo
erectus et australopithecus sediba ils
ont tous une racine qui est quelque part
aux avants
2 2 millions d'années donc il serait pas
complètement idiot de dire que voilà
aumône avait dit à deux millions
d'années alors pourquoi n'y a pas de
date
tout simplement parce que déjà comme je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure la grotte on y
rentre pas comme ça et donc pour
l'instant il ya aucun géologue qui a été
capable de mettre le pied alors
quelqu'un d'autre aurait pu faire des
prélèvements oui mais sur quoi toutes
les autres grottes du berceau de
l'humanité
ce ne sont plus ou presque plus des
grottes dans la mesure où elles sont au
moins partiellement rempli soit de
concrétions soit de sédiments soit de
squelette
par exemple le cas de la grotte la plus
connue star crouseilles elle est à
moitié remplie de concrétions qui ont
englobé des squelettes qui ont englobé
des sédiments et d'autres sédiments qui
se sont déposées par au dessus qui ont
eux aussi été concret sio n'est enfin
c'est un cirque monstre d'ailleurs pour
donner une date
a little foot ils ont mis 20 ans little
foot il vient de la grotte de stars
clinton et ils ont mis vingt ans à
arriver à une datation correcte du
spécimen parce que vous avez des
concrétions qui viennent par le dessous
par le dessus des apports de sédiments
qui viennent d ouverture de la grotte
des apports de squelettes qui peuvent
venir soit de chute accidentelle soit
des carnivores qui sont venus se
réfugier là donc voilà on a déjà
beaucoup de mal en général à dater les
grottes dans le berceau de l'humanité à
cause de ça mais alors le truc avec la
grotte
rising star dans laquelle se trouve la
chambre d'inhaler dit où a été trouvée
au modèle est dit c'est qu'apparemment
cette chambre et si tu es tellement
profond au fond de la grotte
il ya que de la poussière qui a réussi à
rentrer et en gros vous avez les
squelettes qui sont situées dans de la
poussière ils ont qu'à juste en
soufflant presque il arrive à déterrer
les eaux tout n'a pas été concret
sillonné comme ça a été le cas avec ce
master condamne tout n'est pas englobé
dans de la castille le problème c'est
que la plus fière ça se gâte pas
vraiment on n'a pas vraiment ce qu'il
faut pour dater la poussière certains
ont dit qu'on pourrait dater les eaux au
carbone 14
sauf que le carbone 14 ça marche jusqu'à
-50 milan or comme je voulais dit la
plupart des grottes du berceau de
l'humanité ou entre 100000 ans et 4
millions d'années donc ils sont en train
de travailler pour essayer de trouver
des moyens de dater mais pour l'instant
ils ne sont pas arrivés
et comme je voulais dit le dater est
d'autant plus dur que la grotte est très
difficile d'accès la datation viendra
ils n'ont pas refusé de dater la grotte
la datation elle bien et ils l'ont
annoncé dans la conférence de presse ils
sont en train de travailler dessus
maintenant deuxième question est ce que
c'est si important que ça de ne pas
avoir de date
ben non non parce que autant
ils ont annoncé qu'ils n'avaient pas de
date pour leurs fossiles ça m'a fait un
petit peu sourire autant quand j'ai vu
que certains contestaient la validité de
l'espèce et sa position phylogénétique
juste parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
datation là par contre j'ai bien rigolé
parce que la datation mais c'est
complètement vie note
on peut tout à fait se passer de
datation la datation à la d'importance
que dans la mesure où on considère que
l'évolution de l'homme c'est une belle
ligne et où les espèces s'organise
chronologiquement les unes par rapport
aux autres et où la phylogénie c'est de
relier ces espèces avec un joli traits
dessinés à la main
dans l'état d'esprit où l'on considère
l'évolution de l'homme comme une ligne
et/ou comme un assemblage de pleine
ligne et comme le lait dit tout à
l'heure
oui avoir une date c'est important parce
que ça vous permet de remettre votre
fossiles dans ce contexte généalogique
particulier mais comme je voulais
expliquer tout à l'heure normalement
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
normalement on réfléchit en termes
d'arbres avec une racine et avec des
feuilles et quel que soit l'âge de vos
feuilles votre arbre il restera valide
donc si on reprend par exemple l'arbre
de tout à l'heure l'arbre réalisé par
des mots et al eh bien vous voyez que
les espèces en gros elles sont
organisées dans l'ordre chronologique
il avait en bas l'âge des fossiles en
millions d'années et donc on a tout à la
base de l'arbre
on a les espèces les plus anciennes
toumaï puis un peu plus haut
ardipithecus puis viennent les
australopithèques puis vient le genre
homo avec les parents trop donc on a une
organisation de la phylogénie qui
globalement reflète l'ordre
chronologique donc a priori ce serait
pas complètement stupide de dire que
relier ces espèces dans un ordre
chronologique ça nous donnerait une
image de la phylogénie oui mais on va
prendre par exemple le cade
australopithecus sediba dans le cadre de
pensée où vous considéreriez que
australopithecus doit être ancestrale à
homo et bien vous auriez
australopithecus sediba qui serait plus
récent que homo habilis et l'homo
rudolfensis alors ça ça pose problème ça
ça pose problème à la réflexion en
termes de lignes et là où ça devient
réellement problématique
ces homo floresiensis homo floresiensis
qui a vécu il ya seulement 18 mille ans
donc contemporain de homo sapiens et
ayant vécu plus tardivement que homo
neandertalensis mais qui a un cerveau
extrêmement petit de l'ordre de 400 500
centimètres cube comme les
ce sera l'hôpital comme les tous
premiers représentants du genre homo et
comme cette fille loger niveau le
suggère et bien homo floresiensis ils se
branchent tout à la base du genre homo
tout à la base ici comme au floridienne
6 c'est une espèce qui a vécu très
récemment
mais avec une racine évolutive
extrêmement ancienne et avec des
caractères morphologiques extrêmement
primitif et c'est pour ça que je vous
dis que la datation 104 c'est parce que
on peut très bien être une espèce
récente avec des caractéristiques
anciennes c'est pas parce qu'il a vécu
dans les temps récent que la branche
évolutive à laquelle il appartient est
récente et appliqué au monal ai dit
c'est pareil aux monnaies lady se
brancherait là par là à la base de
l'arbre donc une divergence qui daterait
entre trois millions et demi et deux
millions et demi d'années
et puis bah après qu'il soit vieux de
deux millions d'années ou deux cent
mille ans on s'en fiche complètement
vous remplacez homo floresiensis sport
aumône avait dit et vous savez tous que
vous avez besoin de savoir
il se branche à la ban et puis bah
maintenant quel que soit son âge de
toute façon entre deux millions d'années
et 0 bien qu'on s'en fiche après tout ça
ne changera rien du tout l'absence de
natation ne pose aucun problème si on
réfléchit en matière de phylogénie donc
c'est pour ça que l'absence de natation
en soit n'aurait pas été un problème
s'il s'était donné la peine de faire
cette fameuse phylogénie donc la
conclusion de ce petit chapitre sur
l'adaptation n'est que le prolongement
direct de cet énorme discussion qu'on a
eue sur la taxonomie à savoir ça manque
d'une phylogénie donc l'absence de
datation bas c'est dommage mais là où
une datation ça aurait été bien une
phylogénie ça aurait été mieux
attaquons maintenant la dernière partie
et je pense selon moi la plus
intéressante
le débat autour de la possible existence
d'un culte des morts d'où sort cette
idée de culte des morts elle sort du
deuxième article concernant au mode
année dit le premier article est une
description de au mode avait dit le
deuxième article c'est une étude du
contexte dans lequel aumône à lady a été
découvert et encore une fois c'est une
étude très préliminaire parce que je le
rappelle les géologues ne sont pas
descendus dans cette grotte tout ce que
les géologues on peut étudier ce sont
les images les vidéos comprises les
fougueuses
face aux caméras qu'elle avait sur leur
casque c'est toutes les informations
auxquelles les géologues ont eu accès
plus quelques échantillons qu'elles ont
pu remonter avec elle et c'est tout donc
ce sont réellement des études très
préliminaires ces études du contexte
géologique de la chambre dinaly et non
ses études géologiques préliminaires
déjà elles ont montré
premièrement et c'est certainement le
point le plus important que le contenu
de cette grotte est presque uniquement
composé d'homininés donc deux homos
naledi aux mollahs lady est la seule
espèce dont les fossiles sont préservés
dans cette grotte il ya des petits bouts
assez dérisoire de rongeurs et de
chouettes il me semble mais c'est tout
tout le reste toute la mégafaune ces
homos naledi mais ça c'est vraiment très
bizarre parce que dans toutes les autres
grottes du berceau de l'humanité
quand on trouve des restes d'homo ou de
l'australopithèque ou de parents trope
on les trouve dans un contexte
géologique très différents comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure il y à de très
nombreuses ont accumulé dans ce qu'on
appelle des brèches et ses brèches c'est
90% du bovidé c'est 90% d'antilopes de
berbie vont tous genres les hominidés
c'est une fraction insignifiante de ces
dépôts de grottes dans le berceau de
l'humanité pour une dent d'hominidés
vous allez retrouver dit damba bois et
des tonnes d'ossements de bovidés ont
tous genres après vous avez certaines
grottes vous allez avoir des surprises
entation de certains animaux parce que
c'est des carnivores qui les auront
amené là mais encore une fois vous allez
avoir une grande variété de types
d'animaux et encore une fois les
hominidés ce sera une toute petite
partie de cet assemblage phonique
là on a un assemblage de mégaphones
composé d'une seule espèce homo naledi
et une micro faune quasi inexistante
et ça ça veut dire que du coup on n'est
pas face à un assemblage accidentelle on
n'est pas face à des hominidés qui
serait tombé dans un trou
accidentellement parce que si les
hominidés pouvaient tomber en tout alors
les autres animaux aurait pu très bien
il tombait au moins les plus petits et
là apparemment ça n'a pas été le cas
donc on n'est pas face à un assemblage
accidentelle on n'est pas non plus face
à un assemblage créé par un carnivore
ou alors c'était un carnivore qui
s'attaquait que un homo naledi qui
m'étonnerait et de toute façon il n'y a
pas de traces de dents pas de traces de
découpe nez de griffin ou de dents sur
les eaux comme d'habitude le fond les
carnivores
d'ailleurs en l'absence
traces de dents on exclut aussi qu'il y
ait eu du cannibalisme chez homo naledi
si une population de mohéli dit
s'étaient retrouvés là il ya fort à
parier qu'au bout d'un moment les plus
affamés qui ont survécu à la fin aurait
essayé de manger ceux qui sont morts au
début mais c'est apparemment ça n'est
pas arrivé
comment aumône à lady s'est retrouvé là
tout seul
donc contrairement à ce qui a été dit
dans leurs prés dans la presse l'article
publié dans il ay retient deux
hypothèses la première hypothèse c'est
l'hypothèse ce qu'ils appellent
catastrophique
c'est à dire l'hypothèse où une
population de domo naledi se serait
retrouvé là on sait pas comment donc et
pis ils seraient tous morts là sans se
cannibaliser la deuxième hypothèse est
bien c'est que quelqu'un a déposé des
cadavres d'aumône à lady
intentionnellement dans cette grotte ça
c'est la deuxième hypothèse
et c'est évidemment celle qu'a retenu la
presse pourquoi parce que qui dit dépôt
attentionnel de cadavres dans un coin
suffisamment reculé pour que même des
rongeurs n'arrive pas jusque là dit
religion on aurait été face à une forme
d'enterrement pratiqué par des hominidés
dont je le rappelle la racine évolutive
se trouverait autour de deux millions
d'années
quelle valeur accorder à cette hypothèse
ont déjà les assemblages mono spécifie
uniquement constitué d'humains on n'en
connaît pas 36 et le cimetière la
nécropole dans le cas de aumône allez
dis donc il s'agirait d'une chambre
mortuaire accumulé des os humains à un
endroit donné
c'est pas quelque chose qui se fait
autrement que par la main de l'homme a
priori d'un autre côté on sait que les
éléphants par exemple ils sont capables
de reconnaître les squelettes d'autres
éléphants est de rassembler les morceaux
d'os naledi voilà serait situé quelque
part entre l'une de ces deux étapes
l'étape humaine avec ses cimetières et
l'étape éléphants avec juste le fait de
rassembler les là on aurait une volonté
attentionnel d'écarter les cadavres pour
les mettre dans une chambre mortuaire
le truc c'est que cette chambre
mortuaire est vraiment très mal si tu es
bon faut savoir qu'il ya deux millions
d'années il y avait certainement moins
de concrétions qui bloquaient le passage
mais elle est quand même vachement mal
situé puisqu'elle est vraiment tout au
fond de la grotte
rising star la chambre d'inhaler dit
elle est vraiment tout au fond donc si
si et seulement si le passage qu'on
emprunte aujourd'hui était le même il ya
deux millions d'années ce qui n'est pas
sûr mais si le passage n'a pas changé
depuis deux millions d'années il va
falloir admettre que naledi rentrer dans
cette grotte pour aller déposer les
corps
la chambre d'inhaler dit le tout dans le
noir ce qui est fort peu probable
et comme il le dit dans l'article si on
admet ça il va falloir aussi admettre
qu'ils avaient le feu
ça fait beaucoup de si il a quand même
mis bout-à-bout donc quelle valeur
attribuée à cette hypothèse ben ouais
voilà c'est préliminaire
ces préliminaires alors après on a sauté
sur la religion parce que déjà c'est
assez clinquant mais surtout c'est que
on sait que l'humanité pour la religion
est capable de faire beaucoup de choses
mais capables de construire des
pyramides le parthénon des cathédrales
tout ça avec juste voilà des tailleurs
de pierre dubois et de la corde on est
capable de faire des choses assez
monumentale pour la religion on est
capable d'aller sur la lune juste pour
faire chier les communistes mais on a de
bonnes raisons de croire communal et
dîna pas entasser les corps dans cette
grotte juste pour faire chier des
communistes donc voilà la religion ça
semble une meilleure solution
après il ya la possibilité que ça a été
pour des raisons sanitaires
la possibilité que ce soit je sais pas
moi une prison pourquoi pas une partouze
qui a mal tourné mais là on en revient à
l'hypothèse catastrophique voyez une
population de la lady qui serait rentrer
là dedans pour une raison ou pour une
autre pour se protéger et puis qui
aurait jamais réussi à en ressortir
c'était possible aussi donc c'est pour
ça que dans l'article il ne tranche pas
entre eux on voit une préférence nette
pour la lipo thèse religieuse mais il ne
tranche pas donc peut-être ils étaient
vivants en rentrant ils n'ont pas réussi
à sortir ou peut-être qu'on les a fait
rentrer qu'une fois qu'ils étaient morts
mais dans les deux cas ça reste quand
même un type de dépôt vraiment très
bizarre
l'assemblage mono spécifique d'êtres
humains c'est très bizarre
alors qu'est ce qui pourra permettre de
trancher dans l'avenir sachant que dans
cette grotte ils n'ont pour l'instant
fait que du ramassage de surface donc il
reste énormément de squelette
qu'est ce qui pourra venir confirmer ou
infirmer ces hypothèses et bien ça va
être les classes d'âge parce que la
mortalité est plus forte chez les très
jeunes et les très très vieux ont pour
l'instant il n'y a que quinze spécimens
on a toutes les classes d'âge
mais si dans l'avenir on se rend compte
rêvons qu'on découvre une cinquantaine
de spécimens et bien là on pourra
éventuellement faire des statistiques et
se rendre compte qu'il y à beaucoup plus
de nouveaux nés et de vieillards que
deux personnes dans la force de l'âge
et ça ça attendra à vouloir dire qu'on
que sont présentes ici les classes d'âge
qui ont le plus haut taux de mortalité
est donc qu'on serait face à une chambre
mortuaire mais ça pour l'instant ça
reste à démontrer puisque avec seulement
quinze spécimens est juste impossible
d'en arriver là alors une des
principales objections sur la pratique
d'un culte des morts par homo naledi
mais qui à mon avis mérite qu'on la
borde parce que c'est une des moins
bonnes
c'est la taille du cerveau au moins dans
l'es10 avec un cas avec un tout petit
cerveau contenu dans une boîte crânienne
de 400 centimètres cubes 400 500
centimètres cubes n'aurait pas pu
enterrer ses morts là pour le coup je ne
vois pas où on peut trouver une
corrélation je veux dire dans le monde
actuel je vois pas où on trouve de
corrélation entre la taille du cerveau
et la pratique funéraire
on n'a pas de données pour dire que
quand on a un petit cerveau on peut pas
enterrer ses morts quand on a un gros on
peut enterrer ses morts on n'a pas de
données pour dire le contraire non plus
un mais là non il n'y a pas de
corrélation directe entre taille du
cerveau et enterrer ses morts pour
l'instant le la seule espèce qui enterre
ses morts ces homo sapiens on a allégé
culte des morts chez les éléphants et
voilà quoi et après si vous si on veut
discuter taille de cerveau je peux vous
trouvez une espèce qui a une taille de
cerveau comparable à homo sapiens et
qu'ils allaient apparemment d'intérêt
passés mort c'est l'éléphant mains de
sicile l'éléphant d'anne cécile qui a
vécu au quaternaire il ya un ou deux
millions d'années
donc c'était un tout petit éléphant qui
avait une masse corporelle légèrement
supérieure à celle de l'homme avec un
cerveau légèrement plus gros que celui
de loeb donc là dans l'autre la taille
relative du cerveau ce petit éléphant
cie s'ils étaient globalement la même
que la taille relative du cerveau de
l'homme et en taille absolue le cerveau
de l'éléphant était plus gros et on n'a
aucune trace de rites funéraires pour
cet éléphant
je suis sûr que vous n'êtes pas surpris
il ya que homo sapiens qui à l'heure
actuelle enterre ses morts
on a au mot sapiens neanderthalensis ou
homo neandertalensis selon ce que vous
préférez qui apparemment enterrer ses
morts au moins et d'albert guentis on à
la grotte de la cimade et nos souhaits
sauce qui pourrait aussi contenir une
chambre mortuaire mais là encore une
fois on a un assemblage pluri
spécifiques comme mono spécifique donc
pas quelque chose de comparable à homo
naledi dans réellement le culte des
morts c'est pas une idée ciconne que ça
mais encore une fois les données de la
géologie de la grotte sont extrêmement
préliminaire pourquoi parce que déjà
l'un des arguments massue pour
l'existence du culte des morts c'est
l'absence d'autres ouvertures
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure si et
seulement s'il n'y a pas d'autres
ouvertures dans laquelle on sait déjà
qui a pas d'ouverture qui menait
directement à la chambre d'inhaler
maintenant s'il existait une autre
entrée qui était plus proche de la
chambre d'inhaler dit peut-être que les
homos naledi sont venus se cacher là et
dans ce cas ils n'ont pas réussi à
ressortir et par contre s'il n'y avait
pas d'autres entrée et que l'entrée est
toujours la même après deux millions
d'années ben là il va falloir expliquer
comment ils ont fait pour ramper là
dedans sans lumière ou alors il va
falloir trouver du charbon pour montrer
qu'ils avaient la lumière qu'ils avaient
du feu et pour l'instant ils en ont pas
trouvé la grotte rising star elle est
connue depuis un moment et on n'a pas
trouvé de charbon dedans donc ya pas
vraiment de raisons de croire qu'ils
avaient le feu
donc il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
sans réponse et il ya aussi un autre
problème c'est qu'apparemment à
l'intérieur de la grotte de la chambre
d'inhaler dit il ya aussi des eaux qui
serait en hauteur il ya eu du
remaniement
donc il ya eu des coulées on sait que la
cave est inondable donc il ya des eaux
qui ont été flotter il ya des eaux qui
se sont baladés il ya des choses qui se
sont produites
et ça ça complexifie beaucoup l'histoire
qu'on peut reconstituer de cette grotte
au monal et d'y enterrer t-il ses morts
et bien c'est un point d'interrogation
mais un point d'interrogation dans le
sens peut-être que oui peut-être que non
mais peut-être que oui est autant à
prendre au sérieux que peut-être que
conclusion de cette très très longue
vidéo et bien nous allons reprendre nos
questions les question qu'on s'est posée
à la base et tâcher d'y donner une
réponse
s'agit-il d'un australopithèque us to
conduit à penser que non s'agirait bien
d'un représentant du genre homo et de
toute façon le l'inclure dans le genre
australopithecus me ferais qu'étirer la
définition d'australopithecus et rendre
ce genre encore plus à conséquent qu'il
ne l'est déjà
s'agit-il d'un homo erectus même réponse
puisque il encore faudrait-il que homo
erectus soit bien défini
ce qui n'est pas encore le cas et encore
une fois on ne ferait qu est tiré de la
variabilité du genre homo erectus qui
est déjà
selon certains un petit peu trop longue
pour qu'on n'efface qu'à une seule
espèce homo naledi est il une nouvelle
espèce c'est possible que oui en tout
cas la définition d'une espèce
morphologiques semble pas trop mal de
problèmes des caractères qu'il donne
pour définir cette espèce c'est que ce
sont des caractères qui sont aussi
présents chez d'autres espèces donc en
fait c'est juste l'assemblage de tous
ces caractères dans une configuration
donnée qui isole au monal est dit d'où
le problème que aumône avait dit du coup
ressemble beaucoup à et avec tus un
australopithèque us et à homo habilis
donc une clarification de la définition
de toutes ces espèces va être nécessaire
dans le futur
et ça ce n'est possible qu'à partir
d'une analyse phylogénétique le gros
point faible de cette étude sur au monal
ai dit c'est l'absence d' analyse
phylogénétique c'est pas la datation
c'est l'absence d' analyse
phylogénétique donc dans l'avenir ce que
moi j'attends particulièrement c'est
vraiment quelle est la position
phylogénétique d'aumône à lady peut-on
démontré avec des observations
objectives et des logiciels neutre
puisque les logiciels ne sont pas comme
les hommes ils n'ont pas d'avis sur les
questions qu'on leur pose quelle est la
position phylogénétique qui ressort de
mona les pour l'instant et on a tendance
à conserver au monal ai dit ça semble un
peu plus pertinent que d'aller le placer
dans un taxon poubelle voilà et ses
conclusions sont elles définitive
la réponse est bien sûr que non comme
toute conclusion scientifique d'ailleurs
mais encore plus dans ce cas là puisque
là où la presse parle de cette
découverte comme s'il n'y avait plus
rien à faire que toutes les conclusions
était définitive l'exploration de la
chambre d'inhaler dit n'en est qu'à ses
débuts
ça fait seulement deux ans ils l'ont
découvert jeu facile vous vous rendez
compte de ce que c'est que deux ans mais
little foot ça fait 20 ans qu'ils sont
en train de l'étudier et ils n'ont
toujours pas dit de quelle espèce il
s'agissait des ont réussi à la date et
que l'année dernière voilà donc pour le
coup au moral est dit ils sont allés
très vite pour le publier
donc généralement les résultats
préliminaires on les réserve pour les
combles est pas pour les revues mais ses
auteurs ils ont quand même fait un choix
et ce choix c'est un choix qu'on peut
pas leur reprocher c'est celui de la
transparence
plutôt que de garder leurs fossiles dans
des tiroirs pendant des décennies
entières et de finir par sortir quelque
chose
une monographie monuments et est
complètement terminée en gros le ils ont
sorti ça aussi vite que ça venait
ils ont rendu les données morphologiques
accessible à tous alors il y en a qui se
plaignent en disant que voilà c'est des
données préliminaires et qu'il n'y a pas
de datation donc ils auraient mieux fait
d'attendre d'avoir des datations et
d'attendre d'avoir une géologie complète
de la grotte avant de publier
je suis désolé mais non les gens qui
disent ça ils ont rien compris à ce que
c'était que la science la science c'est
de mettre le savoir à un instant donné
valable pour tout le monde pour que tout
le monde puisse le voir pour que tout le
monde puisse le commenter et le
critiquer là en l'occurrence suis tout à
fait d'accord avec leur choix de m les
données disponibles accessibles à la
communauté scientifique et à tout le
monde
plutôt que d'attendre dix quinze vingt
ans là au moins tout ce qu'il ya à
savoir sur aumône à l'e10 est accessible
et puis si plus tard il faut faire des
corrections il va y feront des
corrections on peut pas leur reprocher
d'avoir agi en totale transparence on
peut pas leur reprocher d'avoir mis
leurs données accessibles en ligne on
peut pas leur reprocher d'avoir publié
une description peut pas leur reprocher
d'avoir publié même les données très
préliminaires de la géologie de la
grotte et on peut encore moins leur
reprocher d'avoir mis des modèles 3d de
certaines pièces de monnaie les 10 en
ligne sur morpho source
ça tout ça ça peut pas leur être
reproché je suis désolé c'est pas comme
ça que la science fonctionne la science
c'est la transparence
mais voilà il faut bien se rendre compte
que tout ça n'est que le début
voilà ce n'est pas la monographie finale
là on n'est pas face aux gros volumes
encyclopédique monumental final ce n'est
que le début il ya encore certainement
des dizaines de squelettes qui attendent
en dessous peut être plus la géologie de
la cave est encore complètement à
explorer s'agit-il finalement d'une
découverte importante
la réponse est oui mais elle met son
importance n'est pas dans les trois
points que j'ai abordés et qui ont été
les points les plus abordés les plus
contestées ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
avec common l ai dit c'est que c'est la
première fois qu'on découvre une espèce
aussi basale supposément aussi ancien
représenté par autant de matériel qui
documentent ou le développement depuis
la naissance jusqu'à la vieillesse c'est
quelque chose d'unique au monde et on va
avoir accès pour la première fois des
données biologiques sur nos
prédécesseurs
ça c'est absolument grandiose il ya
encore des montagnes de fossiles
enterrés là dessous pas seulement à
rising stars mais aussi dans toutes les
autres grottes qui ne sont pas encore
exploré il reste encore des dizaines
voire des centaines de grottes dans le
berceau de l'humain
dès qu'on ne connaît pas dont on sait
qu'elles existent non n'est pas allé les
fouiller donc je terminerai sur cette
idée là c'est à dire sur l'idée que
concernant au mot nazi et concernant le
berceau de l'humanité en général
le meilleur est encore à venir